suspender las manifestaciones es el
último llamado temporal del comité
nacional del paro en colombia el
objetivo es evitar más muertes y heridos
entre los manifestantes
hemos decidido
a hacer una interrupción temporal de las
movilizaciones
recurrentes que veníamos haciendo los
miércoles
eso no significa que la movilización
social se pare en colombia'
aseguran que las protestas seguirán en
forma de acciones culturales y que el
próximo 20 de julio día en el que se
conmemora la independencia de colombia
habrá una gran movilización frente al
congreso el gobierno de iván duque
reiteró su disposición a negociar
estamos listos para hablar en esos de
esos y tantos otros temas tenemos todas
las instrucciones del presidente para
seguir buscando más aportes y mejores
soluciones desde el inicio de las
protestas del 28 de abril las denuncias
de brutalidad policial se acumulan al
menos 74 personas han perdido la vida en
el marco de las manifestaciones según
organizaciones civiles una cifra que el
gobierno rebaja a 48 y la misma fiscalía
reconoce al menos un centenar de
desapariciones
a pesar del llamado del comité del paro
a suspender las manifestaciones las
protestas podrían seguir al menos
parcialmente en las calles ya que
algunos manifestantes no se sienten
representados por los sindicatos del
comité normalmente más jóvenes más
autónomos y organizados en sectores
populares de las ciudades reivindican
que el paro debe seguir